the rpc and pc belarus will participate
as neutrals at the beijing 2022
paralympic winter games under the
following conditions
all the athletes support personnel who
participate in an individual capacity as
neutral athletes support personnel
they will compete under the paralympic
flag and the paralympic end them
they will not be included in the metals
table
the 14 strong board which features eight
paralympians was united in his
combination of both
russian and belarus governments for
breaching the un resolution in the week
leading up to the opening of the games
the board was also unanimous in deciding
that such actions could not go unnoticed
or unaddressed
in deciding what action to take the
board was guided by the ipc's core
principles
which include a commitment to political
neutrality and impartiality and then
unwavering belief in the transformative
power of sport
the board also needed to work within the
framework of the ipc handbook
the rules and regulations that govern
the paralympic movement and which are
approved by the ipc membership
in that respect it is currently not a
membership obligation for an ipc member
to ensure compliance with the olympic
truths
we were also conscious that decisions of
this magnitude invariably end up in law
codes therefore our decision making
needed to be driven not by emotions but
by our constitutional purpose and
handbook
it goes without saying
that the ongoing situation in ukraine is
horrific
and our thoughts prayers and well wishes
are with our member the npc of ukraine
its delegates athletes officials and the
wider ukrainian population
i am delighted to say that just hours
ago the ukrainian team consisting of 20
athletes and nine guides
arrived safely here in beijing i want to
know what you would say
to yevhin malashev's parents
yephen is a
was
a biathlete on the on ukraine's national
junior team
he was killed yesterday
he was killed yesterday in a bombing in
haruki
you talked earlier
about
giving athletes the chance to compete
he will never get a chance to compete
again
so on behalf of his family
i want to know
what you would say to them about
allowing athletes from the aggressor
states to compete when he will never get
that chance
well the only thing i can say to his
family is that
of course we regret what is going on in
ukraine
i cannot even start to imagine the pain
that this family
is feeling at the moment
again my country is not at war my family
is not protecting themselves from
bombings in the subways of kiev as i
know that many people are doing at the
moment
so i cannot it's very i cannot even
start to imagine the pain that they are
feeling right now so okay only tell them
that my deepest thoughts are with them
my prayers
and unfortunately they will not see
their son competing
here in beijing and this is absolutely
not fair
it's disgusting it's against humanity
but again the decision that we took was
based in our constitution we do not
believe
that by not following the rules and
regulations of the international
paralympic committee which the
laws that makes us viable and possible
as an organization and as a movement
that took us this far
will ever uh
change what what is going
what happened with their son
unfortunately
russian athletes competing here is
neutrals not competing heroes new tools
will not change what happened and this
is a crime against humanity while we're
seeing here